In the 2021 live-action "Mortal Kombat" movie
there are two main factions fighting against
one another.
On one side are a rag-tag group of warriors
brought together by Lord Raiden to train in
order to protect Earthrealm from being overtaken
by the forces of Outworld.
On the other side is a sinister collection
of fighters assembled by the sorcerer Shang
Tsung whose goal is to eliminate Earthrealm's
defenders.
Among Shang Tsung's henchpeople is the winged
hunter Nitara.
All in all, Nitara has a very small role in
this version of the "Mortal Kombat" story.
While fans of the character are no doubt thrilled
to see her included, she doesn't serve much
purpose in the action of the film other than
to be introduced to Kung Lao's hat buzzsaw.
She may not be the most consequential character
in the world of the game series, but she does
have much more backstory than the movie chose
to include.
From her mysterious origins to her distinct
motivations, Nitara is a unique character
in the annals of "Mortal Kombat" history.
Here's what only those who have a deep knowledge
of "Mortal Kombat" lore know about Nitara.
Nitara's bat-like wings and ability to fly
sets her apart from the rest of the characters
introduced in the "Mortal Kombat" film.
The movie doesn't dive deep into this, but
Nitara is a member of a vampire species from
the vampire realm.
She has the distinction of being one of the
only representatives of her species in the
"Mortal Kombat" canon.
The character debuted in the 2002 game "Mortal
Kombat: Deadly Alliance," a revival of sorts
for the franchise that introduced new mechanics
and characters.
Nitara and her vampiric kin are described
as traveling among the many realms looking
for other beings to feast on.
Similar to other vampiric legends, the vampires
of "Mortal Kombat" are unable to withstand
the rays of the sun of Earthrealm and are
only able to feed on humans at night.
"Hey do you know if any of this stuff is organic?"
"Just asking, jeez."
At some point before the action of "Deadly
Alliance," Nitara's realm was subsumed into
Outworld by its emperor Shao Kahn.
Her motivation throughout the action of the
game is to secure a magical orb that will
enable her to free her realm from Outworld's
control.
During Nitara's short stint in the 2021 "Mortal
Kombat" film, she mostly acts as one of Shang
Tsung's lackeys, similar to Kabal and Mileena.
However, while working with the baddies isn't
out of character for her, in the world of
the video games, the only person Nitara has
allegiance to is herself and her people.
While many of the characters in the "Mortal
Kombat" canon either fall on the side of good
or evil, Nitara is distinctly neutral.
When she was introduced in "Deadly Alliance,"
her motivations were solely to destroy the
magical orb that is keeping her realm tethered
to Outworld.
She uses deception and manipulation to get
other characters to help her with this task.
"Deadly Alliance" even reveals that she helped
facilitate the execution of Outworld Emperor
Shao Khan, but only because it happened to
help advance her personal agenda.
As the character gets little screen time during
the film, it's hard to say exactly what her
motivations for teaming up with Shang Tsung
are.
But if she is anything like her video game
counterpart, she was likely much less loyal
to him than it appears.
Like many other fighting game franchises,
"Mortal Kombat" is known for having characters
come back for multiple repeat appearances
throughout the series.
Despite the fact that she's one of the more
unique fighters, though, Nitara is also one
of the more underutilized characters in the
franchise.
The only three games to feature her as a playable
character are "Mortal Kombat: Deadly Alliance,"
"Mortal Kombat: Armageddon," and the GameBoy
Advance entry "Mortal Kombat: Tournament Edition."
She has been referenced and made cameo appearances
in other games, though.
"I stepped out with Nitara before you.
You clearly have a type, Erron."
Nitara's elusive nature in the game series
makes it even more of a thrill that she was
included in the "Mortal Kombat" film, even
if it was a brief appearance.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.